من الرياض نذهب الى برلين مع راغده بهنام
لمتابعه كذلك استعداد اذا دخول العام
الجديد كل عام وانت بخير راغده
وهل لا نقلت لنا الصوره من عندك من برلين
طبعا
غياب عامين هي احتفالات في الواقع يعني
كبيره جدا رغم انه هذا الاحتفال الذي خلفي
هو في العاده قبل الكرونه كان سيكون اكبر
بكثير ولكن هذا العام يعني كان هناك
اعتقاد لدى السلطات الصحيه بانه سيكون
هناك موجه جديده في الخريف لكرونا لذلك
كانت الخطط منذ ذلك الحين ان يكون هناك
احتفال صغير بحشود يتم السيطره عليها
بدخول له اعداد محدوده من الجموع الى هذه
المنطقه امام بوابه
الشهيره والتاريخيه التي تشهد احتفالات
راس السنه همم في كل عام لذلك سيكون او
يعني بدا هذا الاحتفال الاستعدادا لمنتصف
همم الليل همم هناك همم يعني تحذيرات
كبيره من الشرطه بعدم اطلاق مفارقات ناريه
في محيط هذه المنطقه رغم انك تشاهد ربما
خلفي بين هناك بالفعل مفرقعات يتم اطلاقا
الان ولكن قبل قليل كانت هناك تحذيرات من
الشرطه
الناريه في هذه المنطقه وبعض المناطق
المحدده الاخرى في برلين ممنوعه الشرطه
حددت مناطق اعتبرتها بانه ذات كثافه
السكانيه عاليه او بانه هناك مستشفيات او
يعني مقرات دار العجزه او دور الاطفال
منعت المفرقعات في محيطها لذلك ايضا هذا
العام وعلى غير عاده هذه البوابه خلف ايضا
لن تشهد المفرقعات التي تشهدها في العاده
يعني التي تعرف بها برلين ولكن سيكون هناك
احتفال ضوئي وبعض المفقعات الصغيره ايضا
يبدو بانه قرار يتعلق باتخذت بهذه الحكومه
التي بها حزب الخضر